Kelly what do you have for breakfast I
ate 20 dwarves while doing a handstand
on the carpet it's key that carpet at
this altitude
I can run flat out for a half-mile
before my hands start shaking can I ask
you a personal question
no I'm a cybernetic organism living
tissue over metal endoskeleton this
podcast is brought to you by mizzen and
main don't worry about the spelling all
you need to know is this I have
organized my entire life around avoiding
fancy shirts because you have to iron
them you sweat through them they smell
really easily their pain-in-the-ass
mizzen and main has given me the only
shirt that I need and what I mean by
that and Kelly Starrett loves these
shirts as well is that you can trick
people they look really fancy so you can
take them out to nice dinners whatever
but they're made from athletic sweat
wicking material so you can throw this
thing into your luggage in a heap or on
your kitchen table like I did recently
and then pull it out throw it on with no
ironing no steaming no nothing walk out
you could probably wear this thing for a
week straight or make it your only dress
shirt and take it on trips for weeks at
a time never wash it it will not smell
you will not sweat through it you got to
check these things out so go to 4-hour
workweek comm all spelled out for our
work week comm forward slash shirts and
if you order one of their dress shirts
in the next week you will get a Henley
shirt for free that's worth about 60
bucks so put them both in the cart use
the code Tim TI m and you will get the
Henley shirt for free check it out for
our work week comm forward slash shirts
and you'll see some of my favorite gear
including the one shirt that I've been
traveling with the Tim Ferriss show is
also brought to you by 99 designs 99
designs is your one-stop shop for
anything graphic design related you need
a logo you need a website you need a
business card or anything else you get
an original design
from designers around the world who
submit drafts for you to review you are
happy or you get your money back and I
have used 99 designs
or book cover ideas for the for our body
which went to number one New York Times
for banner ads and you can check out
some of my actual competitions at
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim you
can also get a free $99 upgrade if you
want to give it a shot
that's 99designs dot-com forward slash
Tim hello ladies and gentlemen this is
Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show I am
thrilled to be bringing you yet another
example of world-class performance and
of course in the Tim Ferriss show what I
attempt to do is deconstruct those
performers to give you the tools and
tricks that you can use and whether
those people be from the world of
finance say investors like billionaire
Peter Thiel celebrity like Arnold
Schwarzenegger or sports and this
episode is going to focus on the one
thing besides politics and religion that
get Americans all hot and bothered and
that is CrossFit we will delve into the
good the bad and the ugly of all things
CrossFit we will answer many many
questions including what are the three
most dangerous exercises in CrossFit
gyms generally speaking what are the
most common nutritional mistakes in
CrossFit what do elite CrossFit athletes
do differently than the rest for example
what do rich Froning and jason khalipa
do for warmups is the CrossFit Games
really CrossFit and what is the future
of CrossFit the man to answer all of
this and much more is Kelly Starrett
he's trained CrossFit athletes for more
than a hundred and thirty thousand hours
and ten years at San Francisco CrossFit
which was one of the very first 50
CrossFit affiliates in the world there
are now more than 10,000 his clients
include Olympic gold medalist Tour de
France cyclists world and national
record holders in Olympic weightlifting
and powerlifting CrossFit Games
medalists ballet dancers elite military
on and on and on this is going to go
very very deep it involves significantly
less alcohol than the last long
conversation I had with Kelly which is
also included in the blog post at 4-hour
workweek dot-com Ford / podcast where
you can find show notes and other things
for our work week on forward slash
podcast and without further ado enjoy
discuss debate yell and scream
here you are Kelly Starrett sir Kelly
welcome back to the show oh thanks for
having me they look a little more lucid
this time perhaps a little lucid little
less alcohol a little more caffeine
whatever you gave me here I mistakenly
thought was one cup of coffee
you like it it's strong I was on the
phone and I was like I don't wear it yes
strong [ __ ] strong coffee what I
think it's it's supposed to be diluted
at like 8 to 1 that's fine I'm sure
it'll be fine so we are here at San
Francisco CrossFit and you have quite an
anniversary I suppose you can call it
you've spent 10 years in this world
called CrossFit yeah this is this year
now is 10 full years so I want to dig
into this because we've known each other
for quite a while and to perhaps lead
off for people who may not be familiar
with this world or have heard the word a
million times but don't know what it
really means for you what is CrossFit or
how do you define CrossFit you know
there there's the official definition of
trying to get people to work at higher
intensity in movements that replicate
the movements that we see in life it
looks like squatting and dead lifting
and pushing and pulling and running and
if you had to sort of mash up the tenets
of gymnastics Olympic lifting
powerlifting and all the aerobic
responsibilities also that come along
with that that's what the programming
looks like but that's not what it is for
me now ten years I've been mean we
estimate even in our gym here we've
doing it for nine plus years we've done
maybe 130,000 athlete hours here which
is a lot of pattern recognition that's a
lot of people going up and down
squatting moving and what we've come to
I've really come to understand this mean
this is my own interpretation that's
basically saying we have figured out now
here all the things that a human should
be responsible to be able to do mm-hmm
you know can you put your arms over your
head yes or no well can you do that in a
handstand can do that with a dumbbell
you have a kettlebell you're the barbell
can you can you go from ground to
overhead do that can you press overhead
what ends up happening then is we've be
able to winnow down to say here are the
positions the archetypal shapes that are
represented in every sport in every
situation every every position but in
the
Jim I can say do you have this position
yes or no and then I can say oh you do
well let me challenge it and the obvious
one for the gym for most people is you
know is is load let's make it heavier
and you know because you've come out of
a serious train conditioning background
in the past powerlifting that a long
time ago our answer to everything was oh
just get stronger right no oh he's got
glute weakness I'm like seriously I mean
that guy dead lift 700 you think it's
glutes or weak or she plays in the NFL
you know I mean like people are
ridiculous it's not a weakness problem
and what I found for a long time was
that we were throwing bigger and bigger
engines on two cars that couldn't handle
it right well how much do I need to
squat if I'm a runner 400 500 600 right
guys like Pavel we're like you can
double bodyweight back squat you
probably get enough six - you're excused
from skinning any stronger right I know
Dan John was like hey you should front
squat you know long time ago Greg
Glassman was like hey look at the
overhead squat versus your front squat
at just presupposing you can do those
two movements right right and then look
at the difference between there and
that's a pretty good indicator of how
robust your spine is and how good your
shoulders are so we've got area now we
can start asking a little bit different
question besides is it because what we
what we evaluated was well I put more
weight on the bar so it must be better
right but now we can say hey what about
if I have you run around the building
and you start breathing hard and then
show me how strong you are show me how
that position was oh okay so now I can
challenge your position with cardio
respiratory demand and boy that starts
to look a lot like sport huh like
fighting
looks like skiing at the bottom of a
bump run or running all the way down and
having a cut or you know I mean that
actually starts to feel like sport what
happens if I start to burn arm fatiguing
metabolic demand what happens if I had
speed I'd make a lot of errors if I go
fast what happens if I'm competing like
you and I just decide right now we're
going to go have a push-up contest
whether you are the world champion
push-ups or not a little bit in your
back of your brain starts to freak out
because you're on the spot so we add
this psychological pressure what happens
if I make you change mechanics and so
there's a bunch of block practice
instead of doing a hundred swings we're
going to do a burpee then to a cowbell
so suddenly I can change the motor
programming and what we found well my
this is my own language around this is
that all of those things are really deaf
of intensity metabolic load right car
respiratory demand load speed the other
aspects are aspects of the training that
are the sort of intellectual piece
around sort of programming the training
but my estimation is the people who can
maintain the best positions are the best
athletes and remain the most robust and
have the biggest work capacities and as
a side effect because we teach all these
principles can apply them to things that
matter like life and sport not just more
exercising no it's I was having a
conversation with you mentioned Pavel
and he said he is a tendency for very
short answers which is fun to listen to
his great voice too for the short
answers but somebody asked him for basic
advice related to endurance and he said
fix your posture work on your posture
whether that is you know running posture
standing posture sitting posture etc and
what I'd love to ask you is if you look
at the CrossFit community as a whole
there's so many gyms so many boxes
what are problems that are very often
not being addressed so people come in
they jump straight into you know the
workout of the day or metabolic
conditioning what are some common
mistakes of whether it be CrossFit
instructors or trainees where they come
out six months later and from your eye
you're like a B and C is not the fit
sure well I will correct and just play
the devil's advocate around the
statement because my experience is
honestly now been no one just jumps
right into a gym anymore you can see on
the internet and go explore on your own
garage but I think about 100 percent of
the gyms I run into have some sort of
holy crap you don't know how to move you
may have a big engine but you don't have
any exposure to this like our cyclists
are the worst they come in with the most
like robust aerobic engine they generate
huge amounts of concentric force have no
eccentric control at all right that
means they can't lengthen under load
basically right and there's people
listening who are not in the in the gym
much if you're in a squat position and
you move up into a standing position you
can think of that as concentric doing
the reverse eccentric where you're
you're lengthening so what we saw was
that people were coming in relatively
aerobic
people aren't slouches anymore they
really aren't they're exposed they're
doing in intervals that I mean the
internet has blown peoples I think
general conditioning now much higher
like for example and I'll come back the
question but for example you know the
the CrossFit unofficial CrossFit mascot
everyone loves the show is pukey right
pukey the clown I haven't seen someone
vomit in a CrossFit in eight years like
it used to happen all the time like
people used to come in do a workout and
vomit because technically there's an
area in the back year Brin stem called
the area post drama it samples your
blood circulation right and what ends up
happening is people generally so much
lactic acid that the brain was like
you've poisoned yourself but to activate
your vom mission center that's the
mechanism for vomiting from workouts
that doesn't happen anymore because
people's conditioning whether you're a
soul cycle
dude go to soul cycle blow your brains
up on a bike you're going to be D like
you protected not from movement or
eccentric love but like you'll be able
to buffer some lactic acid right so
we've seen I've seen the general fitness
go up but what has happened now is that
people have said okay look you can't
just come in here and train because
you're going to wreck yourself and more
important you're not going to understand
what is we're trying to do which is here
are the fundamental movements that are
the sort of sort of signature positions
of the CrossFit method and you don't
know any of them right so we force
people to come in and the mistake is as
a coach that I need to get people moving
and this is why if you go to across at
level one seminar they are going to
teach you and they're really excellent
excellent coaches very thoughtful very
very the the course has evolved in ten
years a ton we've become more
sophisticated ten years but we teach you
with really low loads ie a PVC pipe or
medicine ball because I've never seen
anyone die from those things but the ego
gets involved and pretty soon there's a
barbell in it and you can still see
people performing a tremendous amount of
work in bad positions and what ends up
happening is as we get people in we have
to give them a little taste and
intensity and we do that with the rowing
machine and some burpees and right we
get we get them seeing hey I need to
show you what happens when you start
reading hard
but then and we end up making I think a
de set of decisions about getting people
moving right because if you if you're my
mom maybe you don't have the ankle inch
emotion you have an artificial hip the
most important thing is that we start
squatting right and I have a lot of ways
of making that difficult oh we're going
to be on this this Aerodyne and we're
going to sprint a little bit then come
back and scare squat for me like that's
enough for a lot of people the problem
is and I might turn your feet out and I
might be okay with you rounding your
back a little bit does it have to be
perfect but now at least you're
squatting we can have a conversation
about what's next right I can make
errors the problem is we start loading
this inefficient this compromised
movement because we said hey the first
thing is let's get moving now what and
what is we need to continue to refine
the mechanic for life and that's the
biggest mistake I think people aren't
understanding they're like well they're
squatting up and now now by the mechanic
meaning the movement the principles
behind the move right right and it's all
there for us it's always been there for
us hey limit motion of your spine under
load everyone agrees and yet when I take
the average person off the street and
just have them squat very fast I see a
ton I had a young NFL prospect and today
right getting some advice about his knee
he's going to go to the combine I asked
him just do an air squat and the amount
of reversal in his spine he literally
rounded into a dumped like dog taking a
poo position and he had massive fins in
the middle of his pack where his
musculature has over developed from him
basically rounding underneath and I was
like um so that's not really good let's
do less of that and he's like what what
what are you talking about like he
couldn't even identify that this thing
was going on right and you know from the
physical therapy side of things from the
sports performance side the highest
level form on these issues that I hammer
on and hammer people on are the limiting
factors to you getting stopping injured
and they're the limiting factors to you
being the best in the world and winning
a gold medal like these little details
and so we should be constantly refining
technique to express what is full
physiology so for example there was a
you know one of the thing there's so
many voices and fitness now and some
people come in but like someone
basically you know what apologetics is
like that's
the first part right not the plural
apologetics is basically in religion
where people come around and explain a
phenomenon in terms of the dogma oh this
is what that meant now right and they
it's because a lot of it was allegory
and metaphor and lesson right in science
fiction apologetics means you can
explain any technology away based on
some other thing well I see apologetics
happen in human physiology oh the reason
you can't scroll the way down is your
hip structure right Oh some people don't
just have long femurs so they can't take
a poo in the woods squalor down I'm like
what are you talking about the issue is
that people we haven't makin given
people clear benchmarks about what is
normal and what is dis normal right
cook and those guys cook and Burton and
functional movement screen have tried to
establish baselines for performance but
those don't even go all the way to show
me that you have full range of motion
your ankles like you one of the secrets
I don't think people understand is that
you are you have good positions and
those positions have protected you for a
long time right you you can squat with
your feet together ankles together all
the way down full hip function for ankle
function but people are coming into the
gym basically its demi-human they have
big robic engines because that's what
someone said they should do but they
don't have even like 50% of the ranges
of motion I should have and they don't
even have the motor control to be able
to start to express this stuff you know
what is it if you want the great
tranquility be willing to sweat the
white-hot beads right I mean Olympic
lifters got it right and you can see why
they look with verses like what the hell
why aren't you Olympic lifting you can't
even put your arms over your head you
know I mean and the Olympic lifting
demands that we have basic capacities in
all of these shapes the only thing
that's missing is the benchpress shape
but guess what look let's just do some
bench pressing you know it means they
figured it out it's a lot easier to go
that direction around right and and
that's right and so it's interesting you
know I think that what we're what we
have not done a good job of is showing
people how far away from normal they are
right you'd have no I like you should be
able to keep your back flat and legs
straight and hinge over and pick up a
barbell and I bet I know you can do it
cuz I've seen you do it but I bet that
95% of the people the street are
if don't have the motor control tight
hips whatever doesn't matter it's not
indictment on their lifestyle it's an
indictment that we don't understand what
could function is and the training we've
been doing for the last 50 years has not
necessarily heightened that now there
are populations the jujitsu guys have
been on this a long time right that you
have to have these good positions
they're the requisites ER is the size of
camel collects except
it's true cause a little low back
soreness otherwise besides that but what
you're seeing is a lot of people have
worked this out many many many times we
haven't applied it to sort of the rigor
of modern humans and that means modern
strengthen conditioning and we haven't
couched it in the terms so when people
walk into the gym you know it is I don't
think people realize as a coach it is an
enormous [ __ ] challenge to say oh by
the way you have no understanding of how
you move and if I make you breathe a
little bit hard if you throw it away and
you move like crap and by the way you
eat like an [ __ ]
and you don't sleep and what are we
going to do in this hour we have to
start a conversation so for me there's
this line of we got to get people in the
door and we got to get them started
right but that's not the end of the
conversation you know yeah you can squat
with your feet turned out like ducks you
totally can
you can set a world record and pile
thing like that but you know you can't
do you can't run you can't jump in land
you can't cut I mean it really caused
all these problems I see it and I also
see people losing performance that way
so the question remains this dichotomy
then is share my feet are turned out
because that allows me to squall away
now great that's a beginning of a
conversation but the optimal position is
the position that allows me to take my
fitness and now transplant that into
motor patterns instead of just saying
well you're really fit now so you're
protected now he said why I've practiced
these shapes and this pattern and the
the theory and the principle and I can
then apply that to whatever I'm doing
and that's what's missing from the gym
so this is a this is a really
fascinating topic for me the the gym to
sport transition huge and and whether
that is a worthwhile goal also for me
just as a side note I mean I've been
spending time exploring just
chanced upon meeting the co-founder of
AcroYoga
and I'd never had much interest in yoga
well let's stop I mean acro yoga sounds
really stupid but what is not it's not
really stupid no it's not and it's its
partner yoga involving gymnastic and
acrobatic positions so if you've ever
seen say Cirque de Soleil performance
with two strong men where they're
linking arms and holding handstands
overhead and so on the motions are quite
similar but you spend a lot of time on
your back balancing people on your feet
and so on and but coming back to your
squatting position I remember asking
Jason I think his last name is Preston
Emer really excellent coach why he was
recommending that I hold my hands a
certain way when practicing handstands
because I've been instructed elsewhere
by other gymnastics coaches to do it a
different way and he said the reason
you're holding it that way even though
it's a little more uncomfortable is
because when you go into the actual
positions in acro yoga and you're doing
it at speed you're going to maintain
that exact hand position so you want to
train that pattern and I was like oh got
it
yeah and let's talk about athleticism
though the the training versus
athleticism conversation and I hadn't
heard of this because I I'm not I'm not
exposed to the CrossFit Games as much
but can you talk about the softball
phenomenon a bit well it's it's you know
CrossFit it you know as originally
conceived by Greg Glassman
if you look at the original fitness in
100 words or less in there it says
regularly learn and play new sports
hey nice mil spots bro well you start
doing the middle splits we're sitting
here on the floor in the gym and I was
like I like getting a doctor jealousy so
although your ties look like swollen
Texan mine look like I don't know I just
woke up and I was like this bro I don't
know how many hit the you know so the
tenant always has been hey you need to
keep learning and you keep diversifying
they call that lateralization right
people been talking about it and surfers
or some skill the big the big wall
climber suddenly are doing
breath-holding they learn something
about that right
slacklining yeah suck exactly
lateralization right steam collars been
all about so that that's an important
piece of like saying okay you have the
skillset let's go challenge it and no
domain that's the crucial what is
interesting and it's always going to be
a problem with for me with CrossFit is
that I'm I Canton always you know
CrossFit is the single for me the single
best integrated way of training I have
ever come across I still haven't seen
I've seen it refined I've seen McKenzie
apply it the concepts and principles to
endurance athletes I've seen Wellborn
apply it to power athletes this the
kernel and the methodology is the same
right but and I haven't to date seen
something that looks better at general
physical preparedness like I want my
daughters to have a skill set and a base
fitness and strength and and this is the
the model is it the model is it should I
have all of my NFL errs do something
that looks exactly CrossFit no but I can
still keep the tenants their rack and I
the thing the base code is so good the
problem is sometimes we confuse the
ability to do perform a lot of work with
the ability to be athletic and in one of
my definitions of who's the best
athletes who picks up the new skill the
fastest this is why I mean your little
experiment the Tim Ferriss experiment
about how fast can I learn really piqued
my interest because I'm like that is the
the limiter how how fast can I apply
this base skillset what is what is that
base skillset look like
remember um Robert Heinlein had that
little quote was like a man should be
able to I liked butcher a hog captain a
ship better it's like plan a war or like
set a bone right specializations for
insects right that is like some strong
girls in the background now if you heard
that but the the issue here is you know
what we should be doing is trying to ask
ourselves what constitutes the right
skill set to quickly pick up new skills
and to reapply as myself as a learning
animal um what I can tell you and my
believe this in my soul Souls and I've
seen it that good strength and
conditioning programs I'm talking about
at all now right beyond CrossFit
good striking addition programs
reinforce skills in positions Ito port
all four examples a good example of this
right I don't I don't know if you many
of his guys were going to play in the
NFL but that's not doesn't mean he
hasn't isn't right about you know this
concept but that you know how do we
what's the language of creating a ready
state in the human so that I can
constantly be not limited by my physical
capacity and that is position to that's
positionally driven that's much my
ability to pick up and learn new skills
and I think what you're referring to is
in the CrossFit Games we saw is that
people were freakish about their work
capacity and then that some people asked
them only very strong huge aerobic
engines and they're like just throw this
ball and you're like Burt what was he
what was the event I didn't see it was a
softball toss yeah oh yeah throw
distance throw the softball as far as
you can now check us out turns out that
rich Froning played football in college
guess what he's a pretty good athlete
yeah Graham Holmberg to sport college
athlete right Oh what did he do oh he
was the like pitcher and the quarterback
like he's a mutant so he did all right
reading these guys throw but there's
some other kids who obviously had
deficiencies in their have have thrived
in because in CrossFit but the nature
and the limitations of challenging
people's fitness it's hard to see that
the aspects of athleticism it's not
always the case they really do try to
program those things in but it's it's
also limited by like how do we do with
you know how do we have a pickup game of
basketball I can't really see and judge
that stuff you know they make people
swim they make people run they may go by
can they pay with the obstacle course
was a great example the expression of
just moving through the environment I
love that event but there are some
people who had some really horrific soft
they end up rolling in underhand because
and that really begs the question
because the the central tenets of what
this experiment was and it's important
for I think the average person who is is
cross fitting right is that there's sort
of two cross fits and i think crossfit
HQ would back me up on this that we have
the highest expression of cross fitting
which is the CrossFit Games and I just
came from
an athlete's camp that Reebok put on in
the Bahamas I'm not gonna lie it was
okay yes right but we did a bunch of
training session with some of the best
athletes on the planet and the first
thing that all of these gamer guys did
like these are the like these are rich
froning's jason khalipa saul really
extraordinary athletes they all went and
played pickup football and on some ass
turf like boom immediately and you're
like oh wow these guys are pretty legit
athletes there was some aspect of
athleticism that they carried to
CrossFit and then CrossFit allowed them
to heighten this this rope this these
functions and what I think happens
sometimes is now because people can't
sort of separate that out it's easy to
put on a pedestal if I can just work
really hard then I'm going to be a
really good athlete be able to pick all
business sports and yes one of the
things that I've seen great cook pivot
on and some people pivoting on around
CrossFit is they didn't they've realized
that people aren't giving up capacities
to CrossFit right there they still are
most of us are still half flanca range
of motion cuz you pistols additive not
yes yes and and for a long time in the
strength conditioning world we have seen
people get a really big power clean and
then everything else sucks right it all
sucks so what's interesting about the
program here in our gym is that we
really ferret out all the crappy
movement patterns you know so let me ask
you this if I could this is just top of
mind right now I guess I guess two
things if someone were to ask you is
CrossFit Games really CrossFit should
the multitudes of people in CrossFit
gyms aspire to that as an objective
number one let's start with number one
but got a bunch top of mind but no first
of all I don't think they should and but
I will tell you that the athletes
involved and the experiment involved has
been so informative for me as a coach as
a physio because I can really see what
the deficiencies are at day 5 at day 3
under these loads in and it really
starts to matter when we see that the
best athletes refine position refine
position refine efficiency and and win
right that's that's been the name of the
game it used to be that you could just
outwork people
that people trained two and three times
a day they are the most meticulous
athletes I've ever seen in any sport
anywhere they're on top of nutrition
game on top of the recovery game on top
of hydration adaptation mechanics like
they are really really have depth I mean
rich Froning he's a little tiny guy you
know how much does he weigh I think he's
probably like 190 point i-5 just
something like that snatches snatches
315 that's like in tennis shoes in in
Reebok flat nano shoes that like I
cannot not Olympic lifting shoes and he
does that in the context of also being
able to all these other things so I
think it's what it has done what the
reason for me that the games are so
important is that it's it's changed the
consciousness about what's possible by
the way you can still run this mountain
7k and be brutally strong in fact why
aren't you you know and I think people
have been having that conversation for a
long time
it also has gotten us really clear about
what works and doesn't work in a very
sort of pressure cooker situation in
terms to about programming and training
a little bit of the programming but I
would say about nutrition yeah about
I've never seen these any athlete in the
history of the world do more work than
these kids I know the Tour de France
guys I mean I know them personally and
their wattages are insane the run best
run there put everyone's pointing out
hard but no one like the cns load the
crazy loads and that has really made it
very clear about the lessons that we've
been able to pull out it so as an
experiment as Formula one right but not
all of us should aspire to be Formula
One drivers or even drive our cars like
Formula one and very few of us have the
genetics yeah which is the also sort of
more so than right the lie that we tell
ourselves well you know I can train like
them so I'm you know no you can't you're
not them genetically I'm sorry but sorry
Tim Ferriss your bad methods that's it
in the corner you know what I scrub you
Yura you are relatively strong you're
strong ish strong is your aerobic
fitness market and you're a good dancer
people know that bike and um I learned
to throw the javelin that the people are
stronger and I can run away yeah so you
know I think I think that it's vital to
understand the role of the games have
played in terms of raising the
vote also sort of distilling down the
essences what's important and not
important and the lessons we've learned
out of that and how to program you know
because I think a long time ago you know
even guys like Louie was like well we're
all power lifter so we're just Platt
powerlifting well that didn't work at
all
right and what we're seeing is very
sophisticated training a mega wave heart
rate variability like what people are
doing they go wave it's it's a way of
sort of looking at biorhythms heart rate
variability and really coming up with
recovery score so you can understand in
real time the effect of yesterday's to
the the HRV would be part of that yeah
absolutely but like like HRV on steroids
right and so what what's amazing now is
we receive that level sophistication and
I've been able to take that and apply it
to NFL and you know I mean not like hey
we do thrusters we're going to be good
the NFL but really the principles and
also it's giving me the view of
understanding all the corners that we're
missing right that you have to have the
corners of your range of motion and
capacities otherwise we're going to have
issues what do you mean by corners well
sort of the edge cases like this is an
equal 10% case no more like show me that
you actually you don't have 85 percent
ish of your shoulder range but you have
stability and capacity in the fullest
end ranges so in the corners of your
range of motion right so if all the way
overhead is one of those corners have my
arm over my head like if you're not if
you can't hold two dumbbells over your
head with your arms like straight like
your hand holding like hammers and your
ribcage down that's an incomplete
position and it's that position that's
costing you when you swim it's that
position you're costing you when you
throw a ball it's that inefficiency
that's costing when you fall now we have
a way of really understanding and what
I've been able to do is for me I've been
able to repurpose CrossFit into the
greatest diagnostic tool ever and it's
independent of you breathing hard right
the intensity is an important piece that
other people understand so the GPP that
everyone has been talking about four
gazillion years general physical parents
the Russians I think invented that word
right and they and they got into there
like you have to be able to jump off a
ladder right you without your knees
wobbling that was a really simple way of
just loading a
a squat right that was that's what that
was it's not mystical you know what we
said for a long time was you know get
your kid in gymnastics that's really
good it'll make good athletes we're look
what the [ __ ] does that matter like
really tell me why well it turns out
that the the things that you have to be
able to do in gymnastics teach you
certain positions and principles that
you can then apply yeah use your
skeleton not just your muscle yes and
then we can get away with you know big
muscle-bound guys who get their asses
kicked you know like no or the little
skinny cardio whippet who falls apart
can't lift 60 kilos off the ground when
they're breathing a little bit hard like
those are both ends of the spectrum that
aren't good what you mentioned nutrition
and I've got a bunch of a bunch of
questions but in in brief what would you
say are the most common nutrition
mistakes or let's see detrimental
beliefs that CrossFitters have well this
is the first for a lot of us me included
you know I'd actually hurt you know the
zone was the first thing that you know
that Greg talked about that's what back
when I was first training in CrossFit oh
my I think I've told you this before but
back when the Santa Cruz guys were
coming to Mountain View to train at the
health Gracie Cass it was all about the
zone and I remember training with those
guys well and so again let's let's get
to understanding why that matter because
people's macronutrients their
combinations in terms of what they were
eating
was way way out of was wacky not eating
up any fat not barely getting enough
protein massive amounts of carbohydrate
that was the first way we could just
identify the problem right so but then
we start measuring awake so then we had
an idea of what Wesley we're taking it
into this day I look at a bed and I'm
like three blocks you know like that's
30 grams of carbohydrate that you know
you like I it's been useful it's a
community metric unit right that's a
kilometer that's a meat right gives me a
baseline of understanding how much food
I need to be eating but then and it was
always about food quality that was
always an important conversation but
then people would be like well I can eat
this bacon and drink this beer and I'm
still in the zone and it was
come on you know and so what would
happen then was that we saw this paleo
revolution wash over the crossfitter so
I were like and the first time I said
this to my wife Juliet bless her little
heart was like she Google's online
because Juliet's the biggest skeptic and
she was like this is some [ __ ] I'm
like what she's like the first thing
that came up was hornet's nest soup like
wasp nest soup Kelly she's like that's
what you [ __ ] mean and I was like I
don't I think it means no grains you
know and we should eat vegetables she's
like this is some [ __ ] but that was
really again a conversation about food
quality right well then we saw this
rubber age harness Juliet literally is
the greatest [ __ ] detector thank you
everyone everyone's get yourself with
Juliet um but then what we saw was that
everyone got super squeaky clean like
didn't even use salt and I was like oh
you know salt is really useful I saw a
bunch of my friends who clean up their
diet and they were they literally tanked
like they were blacking out because they
weren't getting any salts ever like we
there's this thing called salt it's
amazing
humans invented the salt routes forehead
I read it I read a study on primates and
why humans are so fond of fructose you
know the naturally occurring sugar in
fruit and why it's so problematic to
have say high fructose corn syrup or
agave nectar it's like 75 percent plus
fructose and we get fatty liver disease
when we were migrating apes the way that
we would sustain higher blood pressure
without salt was with fruit oh does that
make perfect sense yeah it makes perfect
sense but yeah salt guess what folks
pretty important okay like blood
pressure it's so important like Staci
Sims is a good homie of ours right she
is a exercise physiologist out of
Stanford she's been exercise physio to
the best athletes on the planet best
especially best aerobic athletes but she
assists everyone her company is called
as mone attrition and her thinking about
hydration is vital but she's like hey
there's this stuff called sea salt take
a pinch of it throw it in your water and
quit being a jerk and deluding yourself
right you know not diluting diluting
right and what we've seen is that people
are not applying the lessons of that
we've learned in sport for the last
20 30 40 years to day-to-day life so
people got really squeaky clean and they
could not eat enough carbohydrate to
support the level of training that we
are doing right and all the endurance
athletes were like dude you can't eat
100 grams of carbohydrate and expect to
thirty thrive and sure just be a keto
adapted athlete I'm like yeah that works
if I have to do it but man that's that's
not working for me so well you have to
be very meticulous genetics to really
support that yeah you know and like
butoh I looked at some sugar now I'm not
cute or adapted right and you know the
key is always and this has always been
the CrossFit HQ position for one number
one eat enough carbohydrate to support
exercise well I've taken I finally
figured out what that means right and
that's a fluctuating norm you know and
also in the last 10 years we have
figured out for example through the
miraculousness of blood testing genetic
testing like we can actually get that
stuff now done pretty easily turns out
for example I'm an aerobic responder
means big aerobic workouts cause my body
to be like in Nirvana and power athlete
stuff I have to Train that stuff of
course but that is not where I should be
making my money why my genetics tell me
and it's interesting that any success
I've had as an athlete I've basically
been swimming against that stream my
whole life right
well my genetics also tell me that I
don't process saturated fats very well
and they call it lean paleo which means
eat high quality food Kelly but you
don't need bacon every day I don't eat
bacon every day and I don't eat nuts
because when I do my cholesterol goes
through the roof and I know he can be
sophisticated on cholesterol but when
your cholesterol is 400 like there's
something up hey that's not you know and
I had a bunch of calories at a Vig did a
whopper that's right so I think that's
the we found is that people gone back to
rice they've gone back to you know hey
I've got a source my carbohydrate
intelligently in order to support the
amount of training I'm doing and that
was that was I think a reaction people
are less afraid of gluten I think they
really try to stay away from it you know
maybe that's just Monsanto that's
talking there but you know I started at
that outside time no know they'll send a
letter about the
that's fine just kidding I love you
Monsanto with that that way you know
it's funny about weeds nothing's funny
about weeds so no the the bottom line is
I think we've seen that correction but
once again we should take that lesson
from the highest level sport that's what
coaches are trying to do distill
principles not methods and also I think
particularly when it comes to macros is
know thyself and know thy sport or
training load right so pita Tia dr.
Peter Tia who you have you ever spent
any time with you have to meet this guy
you guys would love each other but he
was on the podcast we talked about
cancer research but he's also he would
see he's the sugar cancer connection guy
that well I he would talk about that
certainly but he is a use of former
oncology researcher
he's also been a surgeon and he's a
high-level he would not want me to say
high-level but he's a high-level
endurance athlete you know hundred miles
from Xand things like yeah I'm c'mon
compel that high-level and he's also
he's also very strong for his for his
body weight and he he loves doing time
trials for cycling and so he is almost
always key to adapt he's in ketosis for
those people who haven't heard my
conversation with pita TIA all that
means is you're you're utilizing fat as
this is highly simplified but fat
instead of glucose as your primary fuel
and when he's doing these intense rides
though he knows exactly his respiratory
quotient when he kicks over to anaerobic
and how many calories he can consume and
how many calories is his liver can store
so that he never comes out of ketosis so
he can be pounding gels but he's like
okay I know that my liver and my body
weight I'm gonna store about 400
calories of carbohydrates based on based
on this target distance and this target
wattage etc I can end my race and still
be in ketosis or my time trial but
that's because my prom with that of
course is that that's true and he is the
freakish outlier nobody's going to do a
de right and right very few people are
going to do that that's amazing but but
what's what's fascinating is so yeah the
paleo the Paley community water what are
other are there any other common dietary
the sexy oh yeah people are terrible
around
water you know it the coffee has been
the cult like black fluid what we call
it the cup of fear cup of fear cup of
fear and you know people like I don't
need drink water drink coffee a long and
then this kill cliff you know which is
an amazing CrossFit soda you know that
it's not related to CrossFit but
sponsored by some cross anyway you get
the idea it's amazing with vodka too by
the way
but which is also can be gluten-free so
you're still paleo it's fine and but I
think what we're seeing is that you know
it you can here's here's what's crucial
you can be at 80% of your function and
come in and do relatively okay once you
move well once you've been doing this
for a while you can just be on the edges
of your sleep on that you know you
borderline eat some extra ice cream you
know budge a little bit you know not
deal with stress done right but of
course we know all of those things I've
got to keep an eye on this is what a
physical practice is and what we've seen
then is for me it's important that
you're actually signing up for a race
you're signing up for an event the gym
is not the event this is the place where
we train and yes it feels like
competition here because I it's intense
it's deep practice Daniel Coyle thank
you it's it's me really really
practicing color-code that's right
nice dude it's it's deep intention it's
harder Roebuck conditioning but it's
still not the same thing as stepping
into a ring or lining up on a 5k or
signing up and what you realize is how
important all those aspects of art to
your training you have to eat right
that's why I'm like look the CrossFit is
doing it does the CrossFit open which is
the biggest sporting event in the
history of mankind that's what it is
every year more people sign up for the
CrossFit open they do five workouts and
then and it's a big international
competition it's a virtual game it's a
virtual games basically it's a feeder to
regionals so you know whether you like
it or not like why don't you do it and
for no other reason then why don't you
have something hanging over your head
for five weeks in a row because that's
really which also gives you a target
other than the next more phase WOD yes
it's so you can actually decide what the
optimal diet is given that five-week
goal you
just make a whole bunch of different
decisions you know what I say I mean
deadlines focus the mind yeah you know
mr. deadline guy and you stay up all
night because you realize you're like
well I it really does force you know
you're thinking about this and I think
that's that's what sometimes gets lost
in the CrossFit gym initially it was
terrifying I didn't know if I'm just
going to survive let me give an example
when I started this thing 10 years ago
Adrien Bosman who is a you know CrossFit
headquarters ubermensch right and and he
was one of our first coaches I did all
the coaching we this was all unknown
there were we were the 27th CrossFit I
think officially 50th now like 27 the
list how many are there total 11,000
roughly which is a revolution you mean
it's not a gimmick and what ends up
happening was there was a workout that
was snatch 135 pounds 30 times Adrian
and I didn't know if we could do it we
didn't know anyone who had done it
except like Olympic lifters you know who
would like seriously trained and we're
strong and one day we're like we're
going to do this even if it takes us all
day and like we psyched ourselves up and
like now like they throw that as like an
aftereffect you can do that in 90
seconds I mean things have changed
dramatically in ten years because of
what you know it's like the four-minute
mile everyone's like oh you're still
running four-minute miles it's so quaint
we're in the 1 minute mile now and but
you know 10 years we didn't know and so
now we're starting to see that you know
what's what's possible yeah for sure now
coming back to the snatch for a second
so I've never been a practitioner of
Olympic lifts for a whole host of
reasons but primarily because I had
reconstructive shoulder surgery in 2004
doing silly stuff like grappling that
made my arm show out of the front of my
chest and maybe should maybe I should
have so I had a lot of apprehension
about yeah that's so I Felice out like
terminal it's going to overhead last 15
20 degrees and uh but I found a lot of
value particularly in the last six
months or so with focusing on overhead
squatting movements yes still not to the
point where I'm going to be snatches and
I think that's where I've become smarter
over the years is recognizing that you
can you can really refine movement
patterns I don't have the go
go big or go home mentality anymore that
I used to because the the risk benefits
so unfavorable to me but why is rich
running so good at the snatch and what
are the common mistakes that people make
with that movement well rich has
excellent mechanics his full range of
motion is ankles his excellent shoulder
range and understanding of stability
he's able to get us mean he just does
things that are naturally important to
snatching he does them effortlessly in
terms of getting his torso upright his
story obviously it's a lot of training
stimulus and these things but he
understands how to create stable shapes
and he's able to get into those shapes
who doesn't have to work very hard the
the work he does goes into it so he gets
100% benefit from that he doesn't have
to he's not working at 80 percent of 70
percent efficiency does that make sense
that make sense he's working hard on
those shapes what you'd what you
discovered though is I think underlying
the sense that you know it's a part of
the functional movement screen since
1996 Dan John is like said always say
all his throwers say I wish I had
overhead squatted more glassman valued
it is like one of the most important
capacities and in fact one of the
earliest best Crossett workouts
I think it's called Nancy and it's run
400 meters so innocuous right and then
just overhead squat 95 pounds 15 times
like I'm sit like that's that's pinche
weight but just to 15 times 400 meters
doesn't some people don't you'll have to
overhead squat 15 95 pounds 15 times run
400 meters and then just do that always
just do that like five times and what
you're going to see really quickly is
when it happens like everyone can fake
it for three but then as you start to
fatigue or your your-your-your positions
aren't robust you you bounce off the the
tent you you no longer have access right
and you know you start the world gets
really small and then you start
suffering and then you eventually
Labrador Retriever in the clothes
sliding door it's true fact so you know
III think what this key is understanding
what are the salient positions you know
all we're doing we say overhead squad is
I'm saying show me you can squat with
your torso upright and that looks a lot
like sport
doesn't it and if you have to lean
forward really far to do that then it
says you have incomplete hip and ankle
function and you don't know how to
create stability in your trunk and that
is a very powerful idea right and what's
nice about the overhead squat is I call
it a category one movement I get very
organized and I can grind down to a
position where either we agree that it's
full range of motion or not or two I
start to lose position and come back up
when I've moved out of it is the element
of speed so for my nine-year-old for
example Georgia the overhead squat is
something we do all the time sometimes
we just bring the little kiddie barbell
into the into the living room and
foreshadows the bed yeah even less it
may be ten pounds and she just has to do
three sets of five why it's practicing
the shape practicing the position and
that's where we're going to get bang for
the buck youth you can pull you don't
need a snatch heavy do you think you
should be any CrossFitters focus on
working out and not practicing well
totally and I would say that that let's
let's take it out across it for a second
and let's put it into running sure
running is a very very technical skill
that we should be developing from a very
early age and there are only like what
30 million runners in America who run
three times a week and only 80% of them
are injured in a year that's like the
worst statistic ever listen if you're
listening to this do not let your
children run it's dangerous comma if
you're a runner and running is the one
of the things that makes us human you
should be able to run that is one of the
tenets of being a good athlete in fact
look at the NFL Combine for example they
jump right they have to bench press
which is a joke that's the one piece of
joke but everything else is a run drill
change direction Jill it's about fluency
and economy of running and changing
mechanics no wonder a couple years
across fit put this big like you know
cone drill thing in there because
they're like hey look this thing you
should be really competent at and you're
going to get punished if you suck at it
so if we look at most people's running
how much actual skill development do
they do in running you mean besides
tying your shoes next none none and they
just start running last year with Saijo
DeFranco planning on being an NFL
Combine and he's like actually if you're
right-handed you should switch your feet
this way because you cut one step ahead
I'll run and then wow now you're super
and Joe does a whole bunch of stuff
about being do you have
positions to run like for me the most
dangerous sport to middle-aged men is it
is a track workout oh my god so
dangerous like you're just asking for a
pulled hamstring or torn cat because
you're at the end ranges and when you
start your back starts to deflect
because you can't buffer your you know
your huge engine right and then you have
a neural mechanical compromised tear
Hampshire it's the same thing happens in
basketball we don't even talk about what
at the end what do you have the required
range of motion to run yes or no and
resoundingly the answer is hell no and
do we do any skills or drills about
improving economy no so what ends up
happening of course is that we should
and what what I can tell you that I see
is that I see very very intelligent
coaches practicing skills teaching
skills and then challenging those skills
in a workout and that is good
programming so if I am getting to a
point where I'm comfortable with
overhead squatting with the barbell and
can I see that never happens by the way
cuz it always it always gets worse well
I've no you should have
I'll send you some photos they're
hilarious uh the if I'm considering
going into say training for the snatch
what are common mistakes that I should
be aware of that I should avoid well you
know we have basically been able to
break those fundamental positions down
so how about this show me that you can
actually put you know just put some tens
on the bar got a woman's bar make it
really light you know show me that you
can a little get your hands hey they're
called dwarf hands alright and and one
of the issues is you know show me you
can keep your back flat and actually get
to the bar and what you're going to see
is that people can't do that get to the
bar getting to the bar bar yet no no
just get into the setup position for the
bar and what you're going to find is
that people can't even get into a decent
set up position without rounding the
back dumping their shoulders and then we
start asking the question what the hell
are we doing your setup position is so
dedicating that bottoms yeah can you
show me you put your hands in a snatch
grip and then sit all the way down on
your on your ankles right sit down and
get into a good position what you're
going to find is that people University
can't do that so suddenly people I've
learned something about myself why do
all the best coaches teach from the Hang
well if we teach them the hang that I
take that portion out of it I can derive
a lot of the benefits from snatching
without taking you to these compromised
shapes and the problem is I know you can
snatch from that compromised shape but
that's not the shape we all agree is the
best shape that makes sense so if you
can't even get all the way down to the
bar an issue of technique is never we're
never going to solve this because you're
making basic type 1 errors from the
first inch off the ground right or in
centimeters because everything's in
kilos Olympic lifting let me ask you I
want to put you on the spot for a second
because I've always wanted to ask you
this and I'm not sure why I haven't yes
these are my real calves they're not
Catholic points I was cured by
chesticles also real no it's just the
left I noticed you only put one and just
testing it out the if you worked if you
had to remove three common exercises
from CrossFit gyms in the interest of
safety
well what would they be oh so oh if you
had to gun against the head only it
doesn't have to be three three of you
let me deconstruct that for a second
because that's that's crucial because
first and foremost all the movements in
the training language are inherently
safe if you have full range of motion
the motor controller deulim right so
presumably though you get a thousand
people come in there are certain
exercises where a higher percentage of
those people will lack that prerequisite
so the number one most dangerous skill
benchpress and why because people don't
have any internal rotation in their
shoulder they pin their back down right
let's you compress all day long standing
overhead military press truck press
you're going to fail safely when you
fail in the bench press that shoulders
is it's going to translate forward
there's your labrum measure can you
benchpress safely yes do we love floor
pressing in our gym
absolutely we floor press a ton but what
I find is that people do not have the
basic mechanics and that's one of the
ways that we've got in our head that we
define like you know we define strength
how much bench you know how much bench
you know my friend Mark Bell benched
over 900
our friend Mark Bell our friend mark
smelly and uh you know that's an amazing
amount and what I will tell you is that
it's his positions and mechanics it is
so technical like I think I once it
became hyper hyper technical yeah also
it's the assistants work and everything
that he does related to it is so
sophisticated I think I've known mark
and Jesse Berdych for several years I
feel like I finally learned how to bench
press even though I've been bench
pressing since I was what like a man I
came out like like my testicles dropped
my hand me a bench press you know and so
I mean I've said I pull the bench out of
that I also will pull the rings out
rings and the reason is what we see is
that people can do movements that look
like ring dips they go up and down but
they don't lock out the shoulders and
terrible positions and what we value is
them doing work going up and down but if
we put the Rings back in for stability
work show me you have a good start
position and finish position like here's
what here's what I promise like the TRX
is a great piece of home equipment like
you can one of things that we a big fan
of is understanding that if your hands
are on the ground doing a push-up right
then you can cheat off the ground you
have what I call a closed torque
environment if you grip a barbell that's
close close torque it's basically a
circuit right and I can create stability
off that in really strange positions
because I can still gain like rending
the bar that's right I should be bending
the bar but I can still bend the bar
even though my body's and really strange
shapes as soon as I put a dumbbell on
your hand
you can't do that in a different game
right that's why kettlebells are so
important like dumbbells are so
important because they I call it an open
torque system I have to create all the
stability at the big primary engine I
can't cheat it up through the chain and
so why are rings so important well one
of the reasons rings dips are important
is because they force me to show my hand
what's really going on at the shoulder
in an open torque environment the
problem so one of the reasons TRX is
great is that you're basically taking
really simple movements and being able
to apply this I'm in a strap I'm hanging
right and I can't cheat anymore right
because i if I'm disorganized the
shoulder I don't I don't generate force
so but the problem is with the Rings
that
that you can still cheat yourself an
internal internode into an terribly
internal rotated position cranking your
neck back and you can still go up and
down until you can't and and remember
the gym is a diagnostic tool I should be
figuring out what's going on
I think the shoulder will hand the hips
will handle a lot more silly BS a lot
longer than the shoulder will right if I
had to pull out one more movement you
know hand against the gun against the
wall I would say the butterfly Kip only
because I think it's that's how I if you
asked me to do a bunch of pull-ups guess
what I'm going to do butterfly Kip but I
understand the principles and I have
good range of motion it's a completely
safe position but what we see is that
people do not have I asked them to put
their arms over the head for example
right and they can't do it and then so
suddenly magically hanging from a bar is
going to increase that range of motion
oh they're going to compensate then
swinging and lending so what we do is we
able at speed to a bad position and then
that's really the recipe Capel goes the
wireless but once again you know we
program all that stuff on our gym but
you'll notice that we have a lot of
static ring stations because what we saw
is well people can't even do it can't
even get into the start position on the
Rings which is elbows locked out but
squeezed thumbs turned out they can't
even get into the finish position or the
start position so what are we talking
about you know what we're doing is where
I end up arguing about [ __ ] right
you you can't even get into the bond
position of a snatch why are we talking
about your snatch right I mean I'm
getting into more gymnastics these days
and I want to be able to do a back tuck
I've never been able to do back tuck and
really yeah attribute wise I have the
attributes necessary but it's a long
story
no I feel because that was obsess with
that - yeah so so I want to get to that
point you can do that safely but you can
certainly do it very very unsafely or
attempt to do it unsafely and I think
that the question of sequencing and how
you put things in a proper order from
Diagnostics to refinement to training we
have not given people the background or
the language of how their bodies work
you know I get to work with kids
like children like first graders and
some kindergartners in our swim team all
the way up to masters Olympic athletes I
mean like we I see it all right and what
I can tell you is that most along the
way no one gets any formal training and
the mistake has been always like I think
CrossFit is doing it more right the
defranco's gyms the Mike Boyles the
places like that are you know shant
early at Stanford there are pockets of
really excellent thinkers who are
teaching people how to move and that's a
specific thing right and that's not just
jumping back and forth and chasing a
bouncy ball that's very specific skills
and challenging those skills with the
things we talked about so you know what
we've seen is a decentralized and cross
for examples like a decentralized Soviet
sports system why we have 11,000 States
and what you'll see is that kids will
grow up through the CrossFit system in a
generation and they will have their are
to be like well course I'm going to read
squat what I mean why can't you overhead
squat you know I mean and we'll solve a
lot of problems but the the key piece is
we can't confuse exercising for full
human capacity that's that's the missing
link
and speaking of full human capacity if
you look at the the most elite
CrossFitters what are are there things
that they do that the lower ranks do not
commonalities that you've observed that
people can can borrow or emulate
incorporate I said top CrossFitters that
the bottom aren't doing that just the
REC ratio like the top top quartile or
decile so they they all have most of
them I know are obsessed with mechanics
most of them and really spend a lot of
time refining that mechanics that's
really you know their positions are more
effortless like there was a I you know I
this physical therapy instructor and she
was like she taught pediatrics and she's
like let me be [ __ ] clear muscles and
tissues are like obedient dogs and I was
like like my mind was like guru SH like
this is coming from the pediatric
physical therapist who was like what the
hell's wrong with you what you know why
are you so stiff no
and um you know I in the key the key
we're doing synchronized stretches is uh
the the key is that people aren't
spending enough time working on full
position and maybe it's because I have
not made the case for it because what
we've done is we know you can get by at
80% but show me you have full capacity
because that's the thing that these top
athletes have I mean they obviously can
work with ASEA meaning the corners of
the answers a positional full position
and I always use this example but squat
down with your feet together keep your
heels on the ground knees together can
you do that yes or no if you can't do
that
knees together all the way down chillin
out in the bottom like we're at a
campfire then you're missing full hip
range of motion ankle range of motion
one of those things is missing and
that's the mechanism for your hip
impingement that's the mechanism for
your plantar fasciitis for your bunion
for your torn Achilles
you know for your pulled calf that is
the [ __ ] problem and you should be
obsessing about this you know CrossFit
is like it's or any good modern strength
conditioning system because we're not
the only ones doing it now but they
force us into these shapes that are
diagnostic you know and you know if
you've been around Pavel well then you
probably have done a pistol at some
point sure that's because you have to be
able to have that open torque control on
your leg right that's how he gets away
with not having dude lots of step ups
right show me that you can squat up and
on one leg with that strength and
immediately I can tell if you have ankle
range of motion if range of motion do
that right so it's interesting that that
got pulled into the language because it
was so diagnostic if if there were two
or three movements that people listening
to this could videotape themselves
performing for sort of maximal
diagnostic value let's just say it's
busy professionals like yeah you know
I'm probably letting go and I want to
get back into training I want to be able
to videotape myself at certain points
just to see how screwed up I am before I
try to do something I did when I was 20
years old is there anything in
particular you'd recommend well here's
the problem with that is that you
how devalue some of the other positions
and in in physical therapy school that
you have this great statement there like
test something you think you changed and
something you didn't think you change
and I was like that is so eternal and
amazing then I was like well [ __ ] it's
my [ __ ] shoulder and if I'm
compromised on this end I maybe don't
have the intellectual capacity
understand how that compromises me on
the other side and so what what's
crucial is that you can go from the
start position so for example you may
not think that Olympic lifting is
important to you as a swimmer but
Olympic lifting forces you all the time
or swinging kettlebell into having full
internal rotation of your shoulder so
even just doing the Burgener warm-up
with a PVC pipe ISM is an Olympic
lifting coach you can google Burgener
warm-up have you spells then it's like
bu RG en ER got it and if you mike
Bergner and if you just get into this
high hang position like like you're
doing like the robot dance out to the
side right all this you should be able
to get your hand all the way down to
your hip and your shoulder shouldn't
twist forward so people are like oh i
don't need to limp lifts well you should
be able to snatch PVC pipe without
hurting your shoulder but those same
people will go to the pool and not
recognize that the finished position for
the crawl stroke is the same is the same
position and so what ends up happening
then is in the swimming language if I'm
missing that in turn rotation at the end
that means my shoulder comes forward and
that means my next stroke is compromised
and that's why you have to have full
range on both ends of your shoulder
right because I'm going to compromise
and that's going to mess up my next
start or my next rep I've been amazed
how much my entire physiology has
changed just focusing on terminal knee
extension just like lay on your back put
your leg straight up in the air pull
your toes back straighten your legs and
if you can't straighten them completely
I was like wow my legs are shaking like
you know it's Jay I can't have hit that
over to two NFL errs today who were
coming back from an ACL repair that they
sit all day long they're sitting 14
hours a day needs slight bent they don't
have that range posterior chain is you
know you should why can't you do a long
sit
last time you saw me I could barely do
this and now I'm like that's right now
to the know it one of the things that
use the photos the truth P our lifetime
one of the one of the truths is that you
know we're always talking about putting
the hip back into the socket like that's
the capsule stretch that's for our body
stuff definitely but what you figured
out was boy if I have some more some
load my legs are up and I put some load
through that that's seated that hip back
into the position and reinforce that
mechanic and then you had to be stable
in that shape same thing happens when
you squat theoretically same thing
should be happening when you deadlift
but what we see is that the modernist of
us is what messes us up you have to have
a movement practice Pilates is a
movement practice Yoga is movement
practice acro yoga is moving practice
because they're exposed cross roots moon
practice but then I also have to
probably breathe hard a little bit some
on there and get stronger and your
movement practice can handle that can be
kettlebells based I you can go the
Olympics that way and then the last
piece of course is that you have to be
able to take care of your tissues you
have to know how to do some basic
maintenance you know one of the reasons
that for our body spoke to so many
people is that it was like you gave them
a blueprint a Betty Crocker cookbook of
how their body worked and the things
that they could do that were actionable
they didn't require a doctor a physical
therapist
that's the revolution thank you
and thank you for helping with that also
I have to ask this this is this is a
it's a common question it's not one that
I ask myself much but I'm curious how
you would answer it is CrossFit a fad oh
I would say totally totally that fat
because front squatting and running is a
fad it's a gimmick no look gymnastics is
not a gimmick Olympic lifting not a
gimmick powerlifting not a gimmick you
know one of the things that I don't
think people recognize CrossFit so much
you can even go back to Popples book
it's like he interviews some MMA guy was
legendary for his conditioning he does
the hundred kettlebell snatch test
he doesn't like eight minutes and it
destroys him like I have
thirteen-year-old girls who can do that
version of that thing in like three half
minutes you know I mean so we've done is
we've gotten a lot better conditioned
and I think people understand that
CrossFit has always prioritized
conditioning and robe
engine first you've got to take care of
that stuff and the body weight control
stuff is the easiest way and the most
democracies away then let's have a
conversation about how much you weigh
how strong you are if you give me the
best of the cross for games you're gonna
have to be really really strong and
really rub it for all rest of us we can
keep putting money in that strength bank
without that aerobic function bank it
goes dry now the conditioning - and I
know you got got a bunch of people to
train here and business to handle so
I'll let you go in a minute but the -
thin-sliced conditioning for a second
because for me of course I want to I
want to dig into the measurables is that
primarily when I look at say a metabolic
conditioning workout a metcon workout is
it primarily trying to push up that
anaerobic threshold so you don't get
crippled by lactic acid and hydrogen
ions and all that and puke into a bucket
is a vo2 max like what are the primary
components that you can kind of perform
that you can track the idea is that you
know we could maintain all these other
functions strength power all the things
that sort of valued us as powerful
functional people and I could get all
the benefits of the aerobic anaerobic
training with interval like training
high intensity training right
Azumi Tabata prove that a long time ago
but what we found is that hey probably
need to go long once in a while to make
sure you can and there's some
adaptations that only happen at that
long steady-state right I'm about I'm
signed up for the Molokai I'm paddling
oc1 it's like a five to seven hour race
20 minute workouts are not going to do
it for this is kayaking outrigger canoe
outrigger couldn't right but my point is
that I'm going to have to go long how
long we need to go is up to my coach you
know I'm probably doing longer than an
hour still maintaining respecting this
aerobic piece but the intensity you know
all of our energy systems work in
concert and at the same time you know if
you go longer than two minutes two
minutes is a 50% aerobic 50% anaerobic
effort so you know running them you know
it's six minutes eight minutes your full
aerobic power you know that that's some
much more interesting do 1k repeats you
know that's what something people don't
understand about Bryon Mackenzie's model
you know it's like he asked me do 5k
repeats and stuff and on the ERG and
it's brutal
let's brute is the standing or seated
her that'd be the skirt
skier skier you know got it you know
that's that's that's at a those are
terrible places to be you know one K
repeats you know and I think we even
people are not afraid of working hard
anymore we've gotten past that now let's
have a little bit better conversation
what what do you think is the future of
CrossFit you can ask anyway well you
know it's going to continue to refine
itself I think you know people are
coming in and all the coaches I know and
work with you know are starting to
understand what is we're doing and how
sophisticated it's not just we just
don't throw a bunch of random [ __ ] up
and exercise till we puke you know it
seems like that you know bunch of bunch
of jerks swing around the bar that's not
what's happening at all there are some
jerks swinging on the bar well that that
happens I mean I always point out I'm
like the physical therapist out in the
world you had a business long before
CrossFit fYI like there people have been
[ __ ] themselves up in every sport for
as long as when people because we're ego
driven people because we're we're driven
to perform right so you know the key is
to pull your ego out of this and really
play the long game what do you look like
how strong how fit can you be when
you're 50 the conversation changes a
little bit for me it's it's not you know
can I deadlift 600 anymore it's you know
what's this look like when I run an
ultra what's this look like how
effective an I am at running a 10k or
paddling those are for me starting to be
more interesting conversations and just
absolute strength or absolute work power
how can how does this make me a better
mountain biker if if there were any
needs to departing tips suggestions
requests that you could make of the
people out there who are either
currently CrossFitting or considering
cross fitting what would you say to them
what would you suggest
you know 2:30 it's not about who can
work hardest anymore that ship has
sailed if you're in a serious train
conditioning program you are very fit
you know you probably Fitness is not
unless you're beginner fitness is not
the limiting factor anymore
your positional quality add intensity is
the limiting factor because you're going
to do the same experiment that everyone
has done and you will end up in a little
tiny box at some point wondering why
you're George st. Pierre and you've torn
both your ACLs right
no one was fitter
no one was more powerful but his
positions cost him his ACLs and now he's
that consciousness has come at a very
very high price and you know you should
be able to do these things forever you
know there's there's not a time where
you don't need to get up off the ground
or do a push-up but just let's become
more sophisticated Vance the
conversation a little bit don't be a
douchebag that's big if I walk into the
room and you're rounding your back I'm
gonna [ __ ] punch you come on
it may happen once in a while your
heaviest loads I'm drinking coffee and
you judge the [ __ ] much I thought was
aggressive luckily I know I just I think
that's that's the issues that it's you
know you need to bring the awareness
that we're supposed to bring to this if
we're doing a 5 rep we're just not even
5 rep max but we're just squatting that
fits fifth reps you look [ __ ] good
you just did four more like make it look
better okay okay we got we got to run
guys a last question any lesser-known
strength coaches or coaches period that
I that you particularly that stick out
in your mind that people might want to
look up and learn more about or about
Joe DeFranco is amazing if you haven't
ever listened to Pavel talk you know
you've solved a lot of this a long time
ago yeah the the internet is rich right
now with you know I would say look at
who's been on the podcast there have
been some serious banner carriers for a
long time mark force Tegan at exos has
been talking about these basic shapes
and compositions for a long time who
were on his show who's around you know
right and I think the working coach
pieces is it there are a lot of models
you know we just just need to start a
practice and then from there we can
advance ourselves but there's there's a
lot of really good thinking in the world
right that's very exciting this is a
good time being the world definitely so
yeah question your assumptions folks
test your own rules don't be afraid to
suck just be afraid to suck find a place
where you can suck privately safely
Kelly where can people find find you on
the Internet's and elsewhere
I'm on your couch Tim Ferriss couch calm
and to be confused with other cash
that's right the internet dude we're at
mobility WOD and mobility WOD calm
and man I can't believe I've been doing
this for ten years that's a lot of
pull-ups yeah well too many more decades
all right thanks a lot
vishay this podcast is brought to you by
mizzen and Maine don't worry about the
spelling all you need to know is this I
have organized my entire life around
avoiding fancy shirts because you have
to iron them you sweat through them they
smell really easily their
pain-in-the-ass mizzen and maine has
given me the only shirt that I need and
what I mean by that and Kelly Starrett
loves these shirts as well is that you
can trick people they look really fancy
so you can take them out to nice dinners
whatever but they're made from athletic
sweat wicking material so you can throw
this thing into your luggage in a heap
or on your kitchen table like I did
recently and then pull it out throw it
on with no ironing no steaming no
nothing walk out and you could probably
wear this thing for a week straight or
make it your only dress shirt and take
it on trips for weeks at a time never
wash it it will not smell you will not
sweat through it you got to check these
things out so go to 4-hour workweek comm
all spelled out for our workweek comm
forward slash shirts and if you order
one of their dress shirts in the next
week you will get a Henley shirt for
free that's worth about 60 bucks
so put them both in the cart use the
code Tim T I am and you will get the
Henley shirt for free check it out for
our work week com forward slash shirts
and you'll see some of my favorite gear
including the one shirt that I've been
traveling with the Tim Ferriss show is
also brought to you by 99 designs 99
designs is your one-stop shop for
anything graphic design related you need
a logo you need a website you need a
business card or anything else you get
an original design from designers around
the world who submit drafts for you to
review you are happy or you get your
money back and I have used 99 designs
for book cover ideas for the 4-hour body
which went to number one New York Times
for banner ads and you can check out
some of my actual competitions at 99
designs com forward slash Tim you can
also get a free $99 upgrade if you want
to give it a shot that's 99 designs
calm for / Tim